Far across the oceans and thousands of miles from the legendary Hogwarts,...
...high atop Mount Greylock, hidden by forest, cloud and spell,...
...stands one of the greatest secrets of the magical world:...
....Ilvermorny School of Witchcraft and Wizardry.
Its enchanted stone walls have stood strong through the ages,...
...surviving fearsome battles and weathering powerful storms...
...to become one of the Wizarding world's greatest schools.
If these walls could talk, they would tell you a tale of loyalty, revenge...
...and the love that gave it life.
And it all began with a young Irish girl named Isolt Sayre...
...and a unique stolen wand.
Ilvermorny School of Witchcraft and Wizardry.
An original story by writer J. K. Rowling.